hey how you doing folks in this video I
wanted to talk about Arya Stark and her
chances of taking on the Lady Stoneheart
role and for those of you that haven't
read the books she may not be familiar
with Lady Stoneheart or even heard of
her at all because there has been no
mention of her during the show so I'll
just briefly explain who she is real
quick basically after Catelyn Stark was
murdered at the red wedding
the phrase dumped her naked body into
the green Fork River after she had been
dead for a day and a night in three days
after her death Caitlyn's corpses
retrieved from the green Fork by Nymeria
which is Arya Starks dire wolf Catelyn
is then resurrected by beric Dondarrion
by sacrificing his own life which he
does through a kiss the last kiss and
even though it does bring her back to
life it only partially heals her wounds
and she lost her ability to speak
presumably from having her throat slit
and it is mentioned in the books that
she is able to utters a few words by
putting her hand over her wound but it's
really hard to understand what she says
so she pretty much can't speak but
regardless of how she looks she is alive
somewhat and now she is on a mission for
vengeance over her family's betrayal and
murder and Catelyn Stark is now known as
Lady Stoneheart who now commands beric
Dondarrion s group of outlaws the
Brotherhood without banners and Lady
Stoneheart in the Brotherhood without
banners are now on a path of destruction
to destroy anyone that may be associated
with the phrase the Lannisters or the
Bolton's even if they had nothing to do
with the red wedding Lady Stoneheart is
not playing games and can you imagine
being an enemy of the Starks alone in
the woods and you see this figure in the
shadows who is wearing a cloak and as it
approaches you see this mutilated face
with half its hair missing from its head
and the throat still slit wide open
coming for you to kill you that'd be
pretty damn terrifying
that's definitely a character I would
love to see brought the life on the TV
screen which many fans believe we would
see last season especially since the
Brotherhood without banners were back in
this area on a mission of their own but
personally when they showed the Hound
pissing in that River
I think that was D&D letting us know
it's not happening and they wanted this
thing a little bit but there's
definitely still hope that Arya could do
Lady Stoneheart deeds and we already saw
Arya Stark kill three phrase in one
scene when she fed Walder Frey two of
his sons that she had baked into a pie
right before she slit his throat
and Arya has become a cold-blooded
killer who is willing to murder anyone
who has done her or her family wrong
she's even willing to kill those who
have done our friends wrong so it's safe
to say she would make her mother proud
and now that Arya is a trained assassin
and is freed from the faceless men we
won't even need Lady Stoneheart to take
out the Starks enemies although it would
be cool to see in Oriya she's been
finely tuned throughout the series and
is more than capable enough to take on
the Lady Stoneheart role she has had a
list of her own for some time now and
she spent countless nights reciting each
name praying for the day that she could
take each one of them out and now that
she had extensive training at the house
of black and white she could kill them
all without them even seeing her comin
and I could easily see Arya making a few
pit stops before arriving at Winterfell
and with the Brotherhood without banners
nearby who was with the Hound we just
may see him in Arya reunite and go on a
killing spree unlike we have ever seen
before and keep this in mind
after Catelyn was killed she was thrown
into water then later saved and
afterwards she begins killing phrase and
after Arya was badly wounded by the waif
which most people thought were mortal
wounds she then jumps into water later
to be saved
afterwards she begins killing phrase so
think about that let me know what you
guys think about this do you think we
will see Arya take on the Lady
Stoneheart role and go on a killing
spree or do you think that whole part of
the story is dead let me know thanks for
listening guys thanks for the support
I'll see you next time bye